obviously in the toy story reality andy
would have seen the movie light year and
then he would need toys from that film
so do you remember the very first time
you fell in love with a movie and
absolutely needed to buy the toys from
that movie uh impressed truck spit
what was number one on the list what
what toy what character do you have to
buy han solo
and then boba fett obviously was like a
big you know a big one
uh but those i just didn't remember see
return of the jedi
was really like when the toys really
took off for me and um yeah there was a
that was very exciting
for me uh i'm also having an lp a record
that you remember nlp
i've got my record player giant you know
like a giant uh cd
and uh but it was the whole narrator the
whole return returned the jedi and like
listening to that and reading along and
with the book with that
um that that was special to me also can
we just quickly talk about um time
travel
so the movie
is about as the movie is the movie that
andy saw
which got him infatuated with the toy
technically
unlike a lot of people like how does it
feel chris to follow in the footsteps of
um
[Music]
uh tim allen
technically
tim
copied the voice
of the actor from the movie
for the toy
so
chris is actually the original buzz
lightyear the animation for toy story
one
they uh
what an interesting concept because the
animation for buzz lightyear is so
incredible
and yeah there was like the first
iterations of this you know of the cg
animation and toy story one you look at
the difference between the two it's also
very interesting how about the animation
in this movie's influence on you i'm not
sure where you're at with your charlie
and the chocolate factory animated
series but is there anything about the
pixar movie making process that you hope
to embrace and use on your own animated
projects
i would say the thing about pixar that's
uh
that i've always
been inspired by and come back to a lot
and also ripped off a lot and when i'm
trying to write stuff is that
their screenplays structurally are
perfect
and
they really get it right every time and
like you know it's like
economical
um emotional
and i was trying to think of another
e-word because i just realized that
would be three e-words would be really
cool to have and i could just like i was
going to say
engaging hey i'll use engaging
all right
emotional economical engaging
i feel like my word's the weakest of the
bunch but i'm glad you're using it all
right i'm squeezing in one more question
about an upcoming project because we
obviously have a ton of our flag means
death fans watching our stuff and
reading our site is there anything you
can tease about how the show is going to
evolve in season two and maybe when
you're going to start filming it uh we
start filming
hopefully i think by
october
and we're going to shoot in new zealand
which is
we shot the last one in la
um
weird place to try and do something all
on the ocean so we're gonna go down to
new zealand which is surrounded by it
and uh yeah it's
that's one of the things i'm most
excited about for the next year i don't
blame you i think the same is true of of
myself and everybody who watches and
reads collider so huge congratulations
on that this and like the millions of
other things that you're working on
thanks man